we got news about my former place of
residence actually deadline reports a
whole new cast is moving into the
celebrity big brother house i know and
you know i i um was in the celebrity big
brother house first season got second
place yeah i agree with you i should
have won
america's favorite player
uh it was a nightmare and um
i was very proud of what i did there's
me with julie chen look
um riveting television so i'll be tuning
in to the celebrities uh there it
premieres tonight on cbs um i'm
wondering though
of it for me would you ever consider
doing something like this well if you
say something like like if i could do it
in my apartment and the other
contestants were barry manilow and a
bunch of rescue pomeranians i meant
totally
[Laughter]
barry's playing ready to take a chance
again on the piano
and the palms and i are all watching tv
[Applause]
[Applause]
you get what you get when you go
[Laughter]
teddy mellencamp todrick hall yes
another friend of mine this is a great
cast i'll be tuning in every single
night but carson seems like such a nice
guy how is he going to do in that
environment it just feels so like get
eaten dog
yeah do you want some inside scoop yes
so carson called me and was like okay
you can't tell anybody but i'm going in
so i gave him tips to play the game i
did yeah because i'm good at it hello
you gotta play it again you're there to
win right yeah much like rudy on the
football team you're there to win
and i you know i was sort of the rudy of
my season except i didn't win what is
your number one tip my number one tip is
to remember it's just a game but if
you're playing a game you play to win
yeah you do yeah i'm like you we're nice
but if we're playing a game with rules
bring it on we want to win that's true
that is true we have that true i am very
scrappy and frisky sounds like rudy just
like
just like ready
and i'm short like that's right yeah so
all right
nothing 100 or nothing but here you are
getting a degree from notre dame the
best university in the country
[Applause]
if you can watch fruity and not cry
[Applause]
okay good i don't have my glasses but
let me see what i can do here i went
from from 2020 to
practically blind okay we've got a new
dating tactic you can find only on tick
tock the new york post reports a woman
named sophia franklin says she likes to
keep her date on their toes by secretly
sending herself a drink
she pretends it's from a secret admirer
somewhere else in the restaurant just to
let her date know that she is in demand
drew whoa what do you do that
um
you know it's so funny it's like i i
don't think i'm clever and crafty enough
but what would you ever do this
absolutely because i feel like if i'm
sitting there with somebody i don't know
that's in my inner circle i will be very
stressed out and um i will want another
cocktail so i will use the excuse that
it's from a secret admirer but that
secret admirer is me and i'm just trying
to
try to treat myself right no listen i
think this is nuts to send yourself a
drink pretending that somebody what
where did this come from you guys thank
you i don't know where this came from
oh that's good thank you whoever sent
this thank you oh my god that is
hilarious ross all right well next we've
got a spicy little fashion throwback
that's rising back up maria claire
reports that this year it is all about
the thong thong thong thong thong
that's right
um you know it's all about that song
okay well back in the day you had
christina aguilera julian anderson oh
that was the look um uh yeah i remember
that christmas halle berry
and today now jlo bella hadid and alexa
demi all giving
panty cleavage yeah um love it or leave
it bridget i don't i wouldn't do it with
a thong i would do my full coverage and
i would yank it up
slide my arms underneath it
pop it over
and have just sort of a very
sensual sort of like jlo with the phone
but jayla with that that vma dress you
know that versace dress so that's just
my underwear over the shoulders
mine are big enough that if you were at
notre dame
you could do just like lady gaga in the
halftime show you know how she like sort
of flew from the sky i would just like
take my underwear
and just
slide down and drop it
i am trying to jump
i love it i love it all right we have to
go to a quick commercial break come
right back we have more juice news
[Music]